[Musique]
la loi doit protéger la foi tant que la
fois n'entend pas dicter la loi
tout est dit et à partir de cela on peut
décliner décliner j'allais dire ce qui
doit être au coeur des valeurs de la
république et donc refusé tout ce qui
sépare tout ce qui fragmentent la
république et la communauté nationale
ce n'est pas parce que vous voter une
loi à grand renfort de médiatisation que
vous régler le problème
aujourd'hui le salafisme l'islamisme est
en train de progresser dans nos
quartiers et ce ne sont pas ces mesures
qui l'en empêcherait mais on attend avec
impatience le discours du président à un
public qui depuis trois ans nous dit
qu'il va parler de la question d'islam
radical mais ils préfèrent nous parler
de séparatisme avec un s on se demande
c'est quoi tous ces séparatistes non un
problème en france c'est le
développement de l'islam radical
la loi religieuse quelle qu'elle soit
doit être en dessous de la loi de la
république la loi de la république
ça doit s'appliquer à tout le monde ne
traiter il n'y a pas de lois religieuses
vous avez vos croyances ça c'est pour la
maison et le reste du temps c'est la loi
de la république doit s'appliquer
c'est pour ça que il faut une voiture
séparatisme on verra on verra ce n'est
leur écoute
j'ai le sentiment que le président de la
république enfoncent des portes ouverts
ce qui est plus intéressant ce sont les
mesures le concret dans ce discours et
là j'ai la conviction la certitude que
c'est un discours ont rien et je crois
en particulier qu'il ne suffira pas
d'appliquer des réponses juridiques un
problème politique
c'est un adversaire politique que nous
devons affronter c'est l'islamisme c'est
l'islam politique qui veut fracturé la
société française est au fond je crois
que avant de rajouter de nouvelles lois
tous les acteurs de terrain le disent
d'ailleurs il faut d'abord commencer par
faire appliquer nos lois par faire
appliquer les lois qui existent déjà
ne parlons pas de séparatisme parlons du
combat de ce contre l'islamisme radical
l'islamisme c'est lui qui cause de
séparatisme c'est lui l'ennemi l'islam
politique
cet islam là qui placent au dessus de la
loi civile
la loi de dieu la loi religieuse la
france et la citoyenneté
la france et la république française la
france justement si la laïcité
nous avons proposé des mesures depuis
plusieurs années pour faire face à cet
islamisme radical moi je trouve qu'il y
à un mot qui manquait fortement dans son
discours c'est le mot immigration après
le fiasco des masques en mars
on a aujourd'hui la bérézina des tests
on a un gouvernement qui est dépassé par
les événements avec des injonctions
contradictoires des messages qui ne sont
plus compris par les français depuis des
mois sur une absence complète de cap on
va à droite on va à gauche on revient en
arrière et ça je pense que même si la
situation n'est pas simple à gérer je
l'entends parfaitement du côté du
gouvernement
pour autant aujourd'hui quels sont les
français dans leur ville dans leurs
départements qui sont capables de dire
avec certitude ce qu'ils ont droit de
faire et ne pas faire
le message a été complètement brouillé
par absence de cap et finalement on met
les gens en danger parce qu'il ya une
incertitude généralisée sur les mesures
à prendre et aujourd'hui encore il est
difficile de se faire tester quand on a
de bonnes raisons de se faire tester et
ça ça doit faire l'objet d'une prise en
compte par le ministère il en parle il
en parle depuis des semaines et il faut
arrêter d'en parler il faut agir
on ne réussira face à cette crise
sanitaire
bien entendu en respectant ce qui est
demandé terme de gestes barrières de
prévention mais que dans cette relation
très étroite entre les élus qui assure
le quotidien des citoyens et les
représentants de l'état
moi je demande que le gouvernement plus
exactement quelles autorités sanitaires
commandes des respirateurs en nombre
pour que nous ne soyons pas gêné par un
manque de matériel ça c'est
indispensable mais ça ne suffit pas
parce que il faut du du personnel or à
la différence d'une loi de fiances du
mois de mars
nous n'aurons pas les renforts qui
venaient de province aujourd'hui ce
budget est bourré de déficit pendant
bien longtemps
il n'y a aucun financement qui souhaite
clairement la question de la dette c'est
pas celle qu'on va créer parce que on
est tous d'accord pour dire qu'il faut
injecter de l'argent et qu'il faut tout
faire pour soutenir les entreprises
vittek appart en faillite c'est surtout
les efforts qui n'ont pas été faits les
trois premières années du quinquennat
les manuels macron
le plan de relance c'est un plan
j'allais c'est un plan de dépenses
fantastique c'est pas un plan de réforme
on dépense toujours plus en pensant
france que la dépense parvient et à
résoudre tout le gouvernement et termine
son mandat dans dix huit mois c'est pas
et pendant cinq ans dans 18 mois
donc est-ce que le plan de relance il
est au fond le l'alpha et l'oméga de
l'action gouvernementale sur les 18 mois
qui viennent pourraient le dire vrai
dire moi ce que je souhaite c'est jouer
d'un gouvernement qui relance pour un
final et puis et puis je ne fais rien
d'autre
rien de structurant ou alors est ce que
le gouvernement souhaite à peu près
poursuivre ou presque entamé un pardon
parce que pas grand chose a été fait
entamé un programme de réformes si vous
voulez moi je ne suis pas dans cette
position de dire que l'écologie doit
appartenir à un parti
on est tous finalement avec cette fibre
écologique avec ce besoin de prendre en
compte non seulement des constats des
réalités mais également en fait de
pouvoir avoir cette préoccupation au
quotidien
[Musique]